KASLIN FIELDS: Hello,
I'm Kaslin Fields,
and I'm a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
Today, I'll be walking
through the basics
to get started with
Anthos on Bare Metal.
Let's get going.
Anthos is a platform
made up of a variety
of products all designed with
enterprise use cases in mind.
One key factor of
enterprise ecosystems
is that they often span hybrid
and multi cloud environments.
The Anthos platform is designed
to give a consistent user
experience across platforms.
You can expect that products
with Anthos in the name
will have features and
capabilities designed
for hybrid and multi
cloud environments.
Today I'll be
talking about Anthos
on Bare Metal,
which is a tool you
can use to incorporate
your on-prem environments
into the Anthos platform.
Anthos on Bare Metal gives
you the Google provided
consistent experience and
useful tools and features
of Anthos for you to run on
your own self-managed hardware.
We know that every
environment is different,
so there are a variety of
supported configurations, which
you can learn more about
in the documentation.
The install process with
Anthos on Bare Metal
includes an integrated
pre-flight check
to ensure your system
meets requirements.
The installer itself allows you
to declaratively deploy Anthos
components onto your
own on-prem systems.
Anthos on Bare Metal
can be deployed
on either physical or
virtual infrastructure
and supports a variety
of Linux distributions,
such as Red Hat Enterprise
Linux, CentOS, or Ubuntu.
Anthos on Bare Metal comes with
an out-of-the-box Kubernetes
networking stack, including
load balancing and overlay
networking.
There are some
basic requirements
around networking for
the hardware you're
using to run your Anthos on
Bare Metal cluster, which
you can learn more about
in the documentation.
Integration with the
container storage interface
allows for integration with your
on-prem storage infrastructure.
Anthos on Bare Metal provides
tooling to perform smooth
in-place upgrades and includes
out-of-the-box integration with
Cloud Operations, formerly
known as Stackdriver for System,
as well as application
logs and metrics,
as well as the potential
to integrate with other
observability tools.
While Anthos is largely
centered around Kubernetes,
we know not every workload may
be able to run in containers.
So Anthos can also
make use of Kubevirt.
Kubevirt is an
open source project
allowing Kubernetes to
manage virtual machines
like it manages containers.
There are a number
of prerequisites
your environment will need
to meet in order to be
used with Anthos on Bare Metal.
Here, you can see a description
of the hardware environment
I'll be using in this demo.
I'll be using three Intel
Next Unit of Computing nodes,
or Intel NUCs.
I've imaged each of these to be
running Ubuntu 20.04.1 server.
There are a few
Linux distributions
which meet the current
requirements for Anthos
on Bare Metal.
Be sure to check
the documentation
for the latest operating system
and hardware requirements.
I've upgraded to my NUCs to
have 32 gigabytes of RAM each.
These will be the nodes
where the Kubernetes cluster,
and, therefore, any
workloads, will be run.
The other NUC is to be used
as an admin workstation.
This can be any
Linux workstation.
I'll use this node to
SSH into the others
to do any configuration and to
run the bmctl command, which
is the command line tool
for Anthos on Bare Metal.
There are also a number
of prerequisites to set up
on the Google Cloud side.
You will need a project
and sufficient privileges
on that project to configure
Anthos on Bare Metal.
You will also need to
configure a few service
accounts for things like
logging and monitoring,
and to connect to your Bare
Metal cluster to Anthos in GCP.
Now let's take a
look at the process
to set up an Anthos
on Bare Metal
cluster on this configuration.
In order to create a cluster
for Anthos on Bare Metal,
we'll need YAML file to
describe our Kubernetes cluster.
We can create a
convenient base file
using the command bmctl
create config -c and giving it
a cluster name.
There are several
components that
will need updating
in the created file.
I've already created
one and configured it
for my environment.
Let's take a closer look.
If you're familiar with
Kubernetes YAML manifests,
this probably looks
familiar to you.
At the top of this
file we have a variety
of key file paths,
which we will need
for a cluster installation.
Then we begin blocks
declaring API objects.
The first interesting one here
is the cluster definition.
You can see here that we
can define a cluster type.
Anthos on Bare Metal
offers various architecture
configurations that can
be useful in multi cluster
environments, or a single
cluster environments,
such as at the edge.
We will use GKE
connect to register
this cluster with Anthos.
Here, we define the information
for our cluster's control
plane.
In my case, as this is
just a demo environment,
I will be using a single
machine for my control plane.
For high availability, you
would generally want three.
Here, I have the IP my admin
workstation will use to connect
to the control plane node.
Next, I need to specify the
IP ranges Kubernetes will use
to create pods and services.
There is also a load balancer
component needed for Anthos
on Bare Metal.
This can run on the
control plane nodes,
or as a separate machine
or set of machines.
In my demo environment, I will
be using my control plane node
also as my load
balancer, so here
I specify a virtual
IP on my network
to be used for
the load balancer.
I also specify a range of IPs
for use by the load balancer
to expose my services.
If you're using a
proxy, you'll need
to add some configuration here.
I'm not, so I'll leave
this all commented out.
Here, we see some information
used for logging and metrics.
And here at the
bottom of the file
is the definition of
our worker node pool.
The machines in this pool are
where workloads will actually
be run.
As I mentioned, in my
case, I have only one.
Now I'm going to use bmctl, the
Anthos Bare Metal command line
tool, to deploy the
cluster I've defined.
To do that, I'll run
bmctl create cluster -c
and give it a cluster name.
This will take a few
minutes to complete.
Now we've successfully
deployed our cluster.
We can confirm
that we can connect
to our cluster using kubectl.
We can see in the output
of our cluster creation
the Kubeconfig file
we'll need to use
to connect to the cluster.
Running this command
shows me the nodes
of my two-node demo cluster.
I'll also go ahead and
export my Kubeconfig
so I don't have to specify
it in each command.
The Bare Metal command line tool
not only created the cluster,
but also connected the cluster
to Anthos in Google Cloud,
so we should be able to see
our cluster in the Anthos
dashboard in the Google
Cloud console, as well.
Here in the Google
Cloud console,
we will go to the
Anthos dashboard.
And here in the
Anthos dashboard,
you can see that, in
the cluster status box,
it lists one healthy cluster.
If we click View Clusters,
we can see our cluster here.
This is the cluster
we just created
on a set of Intel NUC hardware.
And now we can see and
manage it in Google Cloud.
Now let's deploy an
app to our cluster.
For this demo, I'm going to use
a very simple Hello World app.
If we look at our
deployment YAML file,
you can see that I'm defining
a Kubernetes deployment here
with three replicas and using
a Hello app container image.
Now, to create my
deployment, I'll
run kubectl create -f and
give it my deployment file.
You can see that the
deployment has been created.
Now we can check it
with kubectl get deploy.
You can see our deployment
is up with three ready pods.
Now I'll create a service
using the my-service.yaml file.
You can see that this is
a service of type load
balancer, which we'll be
able to reach on port 80.
We'll create this with
kubectl create -f and give it
the file name.
And we can take a look at
our service with kubectl
get svc, or service.
Using my service's external IP
provided by the load balancer,
I can run a curl
command on that IP
to see that my app
is running properly.
Here you can see in our
output that my application
is running as I expect.
In this demo, we walked
through the requirements
to create an Anthos
on Bare Metal Cluster,
saw some of the benefits you
get from Anthos in Google Cloud,
and deployed an application
to our on-prem cluster.
Check out Google Cloud
for more on running
enterprise-grade,
hybrid, and multi cloud
architectures with Anthos.